There.
There is one person in here,
I don't know who it is and you will not know who it is yet,
but there is one person in here for whom the reading of Plato's Republic will be
the most important intellectual experience you have at Yale.
It is a book that one of you will go back to time and time again and it will
stick with you forever.
And what I would like you to do is to remember this and four years from now when
most of you are ready to graduate,
uh,
if that one person in here,
would email me and let me know who it is.
Okay.
Maybe the Yo
maybe.
Okay.
The boy,
are you okay?
But this is the book that started it off.
Uh,
the apology,
the cryto.
These are our warmups to the,
uh,
to the big theme to the other two,
the big book,
the Republic,
every other book in political science that has since been written beginning with
Aristotle's politics and moving on to the present day is in one way or another,
an answer,
a response to Plato's republic.
It started the whole thing.
The first and most obvious thing to say about the republic is that it is a long
book,
uh,
not the longest book you will ever read,
but long enough.
Uh,
and in fact,
uh,
in part because of this,
we are only reading approximately half the book.
Uh,
the first five books to be more specific.
The first five books that deal with Anne and culminate in the best city,
Plato's ideal city,
what he calls cut Lippolis,
the just city,
the beautiful city,
uh,
rule by philosopher kings.
The second half of the book,
uh,
turns in somewhat different,
certainly equally important directions,
but would take us much more time than the time we have allotted to deal with.
So you will read that on your own.
You can take another course,
what have you.
The Republic is a very perplexing book.
You will find out,
uh,
it's,
it's meaning will not be evident to you on a first reading.
Uh,
it may not be clear to you on a 10th reading,
uh,
unless you it with the proper questions and the proper frame of mind.
So let's start by asking a simple question.
What is the republic about?
What,
what is this book?
What does this book deal with?
Okay.
This is a question that has perplexed and divided readers of Plato almost almost
from the beginning.
Is it a book about justice?
As the subtitle of the book suggests,
is it a book about what we today might call moral psychology and the right
ordering of the human soul,
which is a prominent theme,
uh,
addressed in this work?
Is it a book about the power of Poetry and myth,
what we would call the whole domain of culture,
uh,
to shape souls and to shape our societies?
Or is it a book about metaphysics and the ultimate structure of being as
certainly,
uh,
many of the,
last,
uh,
later,
books of the Republic,
uh,
suggest the theory of the forms,
the image of the divided line and so on and so on.
Of course,
it is about all of these things and several others,
others as well.
But at least at the beginning when we approached the book,
we should stay on its surface,
not dig,
at least initially to deeply.
It's one of the great readers of Plato of the last century.
Once said,
only the surface of things reveals the essence of things and the surface of the
republic reveals that it is a dialogue.
It is a conversation.
We should approach the book.
In other words,
not as we might a treat us,
but as we might approach a work of literature or drama.
It is a work comparable in scope to other literary master works,
Hamlet,
Don Quixote,
Warren piece,
others you might think of
it as a conversation is a dialogue.
It is something that the author wants us to join to take part in.
We were invited to be not merely passive onlookers of this conversation,
but active participants in that dialogue that takes place in this book over the
course of a single evening.
Perhaps the best way to read this book is to read it aloud as you might with a
play to yourself or with your friends,
but let's go a little further.
The republic is also a utopia.
A word that Plato does not use was not coined in too many,
many centuries later by Sir Thomas Moore.
But Plato's book is a utopia.
It is a kind of extreme.
You present an extreme vision of politics.
He presents an extreme vision of the Polis.
The guiding thread of the book is the correspondence.
And we will look at this in some length and you will discuss in your sections,
no doubt the guiding thread of the book is the correspondence,
the symmetry between the parts of the city and the parts of the soul
discord within the city.
Uh,
just as discord within the soul is regarded as the greatest evil.
The aim of the republic is to establish a harmonious city based on a conception
of justice.
That so to speak,
harmonizes the individual and society.
How,
how to achieve that the best city,
uh,
will necessarily be one that seeks to produce the best or highest type of
individual.
And Plato's famous answer to this is that the city,
any,
any city will never be free of conflict.
We'll never be free of factional strife until in his famous formula,
kings become philosophers and philosophers become kings.
Okay.
Republic asks us to consider seriously,
what would a city look like ruled by philosophers
in this respect.
It would seem to be the sort of perfect bookend to the apology.
Remember the apology,
uh,
viewed the dangers posed to philosophy and the philosopher and the philosophical
life from the city.
The republic asks us,
what would a city be like if it were ruled by Socrates or someone like him?
What would it be like for philosophers to rule such as city would require?
So Socrates tells us throughout the opening books the severe censorship of
Poetry and theology,
the abolition of private property and the family,
at least among the Guardian class of the city.
And the use of selected lies and myths.
What would today probably be called ideology or propaganda is tools of political
rule.
It would seem that far from utopia.
The Republic represents a radical Dystopia,
a satire in some sense of the best polity.
And in fact,
much of modern political science is directed against Plato's legacy.
The modern state is,
we have come to understand it is based upon the separation of civil society from
governing authority,
the entire domain of private,
what we call private life separated from the state.
But Plato's republic recognizes no such separation or no such independence,
uh,
for a private sphere.
And for this reason,
Plato has often been cast as a kind of harbinger a of the modern totalitarian
state.
A famous professor at a distance university was said to have begun his lectures
on the republic by saying,
now we will consider Plato the fascist.
And this was in fact the view popularized by one of the most influential books
about Plato written in the last century.
A book written by a Viennese emigre by the name of Karl Popper,
who in the very early 1950s,
right at the height of the Cold War.
And of course the end of the conclusion of the Second World War wrote a book
called the Open Society and its enemies.
He wanted to know,
uh,
what were the causes or who were the responsible for the exp experiences of
totalitarianism,
both in Stalin's Russia and it Hitler's Germany.
And in the course of this inquiry,
he concluded that not only Hegel and Marx were important in that particular
genealogy,
but this went back to Plato as well.
Prep Plato principally a Plato who he accuses popper and a passionate,
uh,
albeit not very well written book,
accuses a Plato of,
of a stab being the first to establish a kind of totalitarian dictatorship.
Is that true?
Well,
Plato's republic is,
we will discover as you read,
it is a republic of a very special kind.
It is not a regime like hours devoted to maximizing individual liberties,
but it is one that puts the education of its citizens,
the education of its members as its highest duty
republic.
Like the Greek Paullus was a kind of tootle area association and its principal
good.
It's principal goal was the education of citizens for positions of public
leadership and high political responsibilities.
It is always worthwhile to remember that Plato was above all a teacher.
He was the founder of the first university,
the academy,
the Platonic Academy,
where we will find out later,
Aristotle came to study among among many others,
Aristotle being,
but the most famous Plato was a founder of this school and this intern spawned
other philosophical schools throughout the Greek world and later the Roman
world.
Okay.
With the demise of Rome in the early Christian centuries,
these philosophical academies,
these philosophical schools were absorbed into the medieval monasteries and
these in turn became the basis of the first European universities and places
like Bologna,
Paris,
Oxford,
these were in turn later transplanted to the new world and established in towns
like Cambridge and of course,
new haven.
We can say today that this university is a direct ancestor of the Platonic
Republic of Plato's academy.
We are all here,
the heirs of Plato.
Think of that without Plato,
no Yale,
we would not be here today
and I think that is a fact.
You just ponder that for a moment
and in fact,
let me even say a little more about this.
The institutional and educational requirements of Plato's Republic share many
features with a place like Yale.
For example,
in both the platonic ca Lippolis,
the just city as well as this place,
men and women,
men and women
are selected at a relatively early age because of their capacities for
leadership,
for courage,
for self discipline and responsibility.
They spend several years living together,
eating together and common mess halls,
exercising together and studying together of course,
far from the oversight of their parents.
The best of them are winnowed out to pursue further study and eventually assume
positions of public leadership and responsibility.
Throughout all of this,
they are subjected to a course of rigorous study and physical training that will
lead them to adopt prominent positions in the military and other branches of
public service.
Does this sound at all familiar to you?
It should.
Let me put it another way.
If Plato is,
is a fascist,
what does that make you?
Okay.
Plato of course,
is an extremist and he pushes his ideas to their most radical conclusions.
That's what it is to be a philosopher,
but he is also defining a kind of school.
He regards the politics or the republic because that is the original Greek title
of the book,
polity or,
or regime.
Uh,
he regards the polar Taher is a score.
Who's chief goal is preparation for guidance and leadership of a community.
If you don't believe me about this,
maybe you will consider the words of John Jack Russell,
one of the great readers of Plato's Republic Russo wrote in is a meal to get a
good idea of public education.
He says,
read Plato's Republic.
It is not a political treatise as those who merely judge books by their title.
Think.
But it is the finest,
most beautiful work on education ever written.
Roussel
so
here we go.
Let's
look in a little.
That's what's now peak into the book itself.
Just peak.
Well,
go too far.
Start with the first line.
Who remembers what the first line is?
Oh,
come on.
You should know this.
It's now you're looking at the book.
You're cheating.
I went down to the Pi Radius.
Why does Plato Begin with this line?
Here's a story that I heard.
I'm not sure altogether true,
but it's a good story.
And at least about the famous German philosopher Martin Heidegger,
who said that,
uh,
on his first teaching of the republic,
he went through the whole book,
taught throughout the whole book in one in one class,
in one seminar,
one semester.
The last time he taught at the final time,
he taught it.
He never got beyond the first sentence.
I went down to the [inaudible].
What does it mean?
Why does he begin with this?
I went down a going down,
the Greek word for this is Khattab Asus.
I had made a descent.
There is a book by a famous contemporary of Plato's [inaudible] name's Xenophon,
who wrote a book called the analysis.
The analysis means a going up and us an s sent.
But Plato begins this dialogue with the stigma.
I went down
the descent to the pirates.
It is clearly modeled on Odysseus's descent to Haiti's in the,
in the Odyssey.
And in fact the work is a kind of philosophical odyssey that both imitates homer
but also anticipates other great odyssey's of the human mind works by those like
Servon tastes or,
or Joyce.
The book is full.
You will see other number of descents and essence,
the most famous climb upward,
uh,
although we will not actually read these parts for this class.
Concerns the climb of to the divided line,
the famous image of the divided line in book six and the assent to the world of
the imperishable forms.
And then in the last book of the Republic Book 10,
there is once again a descent to the underworld,
to the world of,
of Haiti's.
Uh,
the work is not in a sense written simply as a sort of timeless philosophical
treatise,
but as a dramatic dialogue with a setting,
a cast of characters and affirm location in time and place.
Let's say a little more about that time and place already indicated in this.
In the phrase or sentence.
I went down to the Pi Radius.
Plato was born in four 27,
which is four years after the commencement of the Peloponnesian war.
He was a young man of 23 when the democracy in Athens was defeated,
and he was only 28 when the restored democracy executed his friend and teacher
Socrates in three 99
almost immediately after the trial of Socrates,
Plato left Athens and traveled extensively throughout the Greek world.
And upon his return,
he established this school at Athens called the academy for the training of
philosophers,
statesmen,
and legislators.
Plato lived a long time.
He lived until the age of 80,
and except for two expeditions to Sicily where he went at the request of
Dionysius to help try to establish a philosophical kingship,
uh,
in Syracuse.
Uh,
he remained in Athens,
teaching and writing.
The republic
belongs to that period of Plato's work after his return to Athens,
after the execution of Socrates,
the dominant feature of Plato's political theory,
David Green,
a great reader of Plato has said,
is the root and branch character of the change.
It advocates and existing institutions.
Plato desire for a kind of radical make-over of Athenian and Greek political
institutions and cultures grew out of his experience of political defeat and
despair.
The utopianism of the book is in many ways the reverse side of the sense of
profound disillusionment that he felt at the actual experience of the Athenian
Polis.
This was not only true of his experience at home,
but as his failed efforts to turn,
uh,
Dionysius Dionysius his kingship in Sicily into a successful example of
philosophical rule.
In fact,
we have,
and I want to read to you in just a moment,
a lengthy transcript of Plato's own account of why he came to write the
republic.
One one thing of course,
you note in the republic is that Plato is nowhere present.
He is not a participant in his own dialog.
He is the author but not the participant.
We don't know precisely what played,
what Plato thought,
but we are helped at least by a kind of intellectual that he wrote and that we
still have,
uh,
in what is conventionally referred to as the seventh letter.
P Plato wrote a series of letters that we have.
People have argued over the authenticity of them,
although I think by now it is established that they are his.
And in the most famous of these letters,
the lengthy seventh one,
he gives us again,
something of an autobiography and tells us a little bit about why he came to
write this book is,
isn't this amazing that you know,
2020 500 years ago,
we still have the letters of the man who wrote this book.
So let me read to you what Plato says about how he came to write this book.
When I was a young man.
He said,
and this is written as he's very old.
When I was a young man,
I felt as many young men do.
I felt at the very moment I attained my majority,
I should engage in public affairs.
And there came my way and opportunity that I want to tell you about
the democratic constitution.
Then loudly decried by many people was abolished and the leaders of the
revolution set themselves up as a government of 30 men with Supreme Authority.
This is,
he's referring to the tyranny of the 30 that existed after the Athenian defeat.
Some of these men,
some of the members of the 30,
you must understand,
were relatives of mine and well known to me.
And what is more,
they actually invited me at once to join them is no politics and I were a fit
match.
I was very young then.
And it is not surprising that I felt as I did,
I thought that the city was then living a kind of life which was unjust and that
they would bend it to adjust one and so it administer it more justly.
So I eagerly watch to see what they would do.
And you must know as I looked on,
I saw those men in a short time make the former democracy look like a golden
age.
Those are the referring to his relatives.
Men like Critias and comedies,
uh,
who,
turned,
uh,
Athenian politics into a tyranny and which he says makes the democracy looked
like a golden age.
Let me continue in Plato's words.
I looked at this,
you see,
and at the men who were in politics at the laws and customs and the more I
looked and the older I grew,
the more difficult it seemed to me to administer political affairs justly for
you cannot do so without friends and comrades you can trust and such men,
it was not easy to find for the city you see no longer lived in the fashion and
ways of our fathers eager as I had once been to go into politics is I look at
these things and saw everything taking any course at all with no direction or
management.
I ended up feeling dizzy.
I did not abandoned my interest in politics,
do to discover how it might be better than other respects and I was perpetually
awaiting my opportunity.
But at last I saw that as far as all states now existing are concerned,
they are all badly governed for the condition of their laws is bad.
Almost passed cure except for some miraculous accident.
So I was compelled to say and praise and true philosophy that it was from it
alone that was able to discern any justice.
And so I said that the nations of the world will never cease from trouble until
either the true breed of philosophers shall come to political office or until
that of the rulers shell by some divine law take to the pursuit of philosophy.
And there you see in that,
you know,
wonderful letter and that kind of probing self examination of his early motives
and,
and uh,
and expectations.
You see the disillusionment of the,
uh,
of the older,
Plato Looking,
looking on what is,
what,
what the tyranny had done,
but also looking at the states,
the nations of his time,
uh,
seeing,
their management,
seeing their decay and conflict and saying and suggesting that no,
uh,
no justice will ever be expected until,
as he says at the end,
kings become philosophers and philosophers,
Keynes,
a direct reference to the,
to,
to the republic.
This little autobiography he goes on at considerably greater length,
I should say.
But this provides a kind of introduction as it were to the republic.
We haven't Plato's own words here,
the way he viewed politics and his reasons for his political philosophy.
And yet in many respects,
if the republic was the result of comprehensive despair and disillusionment with
the prospects of reform,
the dialogue itself points back to an earlier moment in Plato's life and the
life of the city of Athens.
Uh,
this remarkable letter was written when Plato was very old,
uh,
approximately 50 years after the trial and execution of Socrates.
But the action of the republic takes place long before the defeat of Athens,
uh,
before the rise of the 30 and the execution of Athens.
It refers to that period that Plato says in the letter looked like a golden age
when many things seemed possible.
And that brings us back to the opening,
the descent to the Pi Radius.
The action of the dialogue begins at the Pi Radius,
the port city of Athens,
somewhere around the year for 11,
uh,
during what was called the piece of Nikias.
That is to say the PR piece that endured a kind of respite truce that was
established during the fighting between Sparta and Athens.
And at the very beginning of the dialogue,
we see Socrates and his friend Glaucon.
What are they doing?
Do you remember?
What are they doing at the very beginning?
Where,
right.
Let me put it a slightly here.
Yes,
they are walking back to Athens from my the Pi Radius,
but maybe to put it a slightly different way.
They're trolling the waterfront.
What is the Pi Radius?
It is the harbor of Athens and what do you expect from harbors?
What our harbor cities like?
What do you find down at harbors?
Okay,
there's CD,
aren't they?
They're kind of,
you find various kinds of disreputable and maybe unseemly things going on there.
We are forced to ask ourselves,
what are Socrates and Glaucon doing there?
Why are they there together?
What are they,
what are they doing?
What do they expect to find?
These seem to be questions that immediately come to mind.
We learned shortly afterwards that they have taken this descent,
the pro Reyes to have your festival kind of carnival.
It sounds like something one might expect to see in a Fellini film,
a kind of carnival carnival,
a Mardi gras.
We're a festival is going on and what,
what's more a new goddess is being introduced into the Pantheon of deities.
Uh,
this seems to suggest that referring back to the apology,
that it is not Socrates,
the Athenians who innovate,
who create an in in introduced new deities,
Socrates remarks that the,
uh,
thracians the display of the thracians put on a good show showing that his own
perspective is not simply bound by that of his city.
It suggests from the beginning of kind of loftiness and impartiality of
perspective characteristic of the philosopher,
but not necessarily the citizen.
And on their way back from this festival,
from the,
from this carnival on their way back,
they were accosted.
You remember they are costed by a slave who's been sent on by Paula Marcus and
his friends and who orders Socrates and Glaucon to wait.
Paula Marcus orders you to weight.
The slave says he orders you to wait.
He coming up behind you.
Just wait.
And of course we'll wait.
Glaucon replies.
When Paula Marcus and his friends arrive,
we find that his friends include Eddie Mantis who was glaucoma,
his brother in Nicole Rogers who was the son of Nikias,
the general who was just brokered the peace that they are now enjoying.
So famous piece of Nikki as when they Charlotte challenge Socrates,
stay with us or prove stronger,
stay with us or prove stronger.
Could we not persuade you?
Socrates asked,
could we not persuade you to let us go?
Not if we won't listen.
Paul Lamarca says,
and instead they reach a compromise.
Let's Socrates,
let's Socrates and Glaucon come with parlor Marcus and the others to the home of
parlor.
Marcus,
his father,
we're at dinner,
will be provided for them and later a return to the festival where there will be
a horseback race.
It seems Glaucon says we must stay in Socrates.
Concur's.
Why does the book begin with this?
You want to say opening gambit is it's simply a ruse to get the reader's
attention and some sense or to kind of rope you in with some promise of what's
to follow.
Already from the very opening lines we see in this a clue to the,
to the theme that is that is going to follow who has the title to rule?
Is it Paula Marcus and his friends who claimed to rule by strength of numbers?
Can we persuade you?
Not If we don't listen,
he says,
or Socrates and Glaucon who hope to rule by the powers of reason to speech and
argument.
Can we convince you?
Can we persuade you?
Can Democracy that expresses the will of the majority,
the will of the greater number be rendered compatible with the needs of
philosophy and the reclaims to respect only reason and the better argument.
That seems to be the question already posed in this opening scene.
Can a compromise be reached between the two?
Uh,
can the strength of numbers as well as respect for reason and the better
argument be in some sense a harmonized,
can they be,
uh,
can they be brought together?
Is the just city perhaps that Socrates,
we'll later consider a combination of these two of both force and persuasion.
That will be something left to see.
But I think you can see the big themes of the book already very present in the
opening scene,
uh,
that this,
of the dialogue when the first book is really a kind of preamble to everything
that follows.
Okay.
You're with me so far on this.
Let's talk
a little bit about the participants in this dialogue.
It is a dialogue.
It has a number of,
uh,
a fairly large number of characters,
although only a relatively few number of them,
uh,
speak,
in the book.
Uh,
and yet it's something very important,
uh,
as we would want to know in any play or novel or movie.
Uh,
we want to note something about,
uh,
the particular people who
inhabit this,
this dinner party that Socrates and Glaucon have been promised.
Who are they and what do they represent?
Uh,
there is capitalists,
we will see very quickly the father of Paula Marcus and whose home they are
attending a,
the venerable Pocho familiars,
the venerable father of the family,
Paula Marcus,
his son,
a solid patriot who defends not only his father's honor,
but that of his friends and fellow citizens.
And we will also see through civicus,
Ahh,
a cynical intellectual who rivals Socrates as an educator of future leaders and
statesmen.
And of course it is the exchange between Socrates and Thrasymachus.
That is one of the most famous moments of the book.
And there is in the first set of dialogues,
it distinct hierarchy of characters,
you might say,
who we see later on express those distinctive features of the soul and the city
capitalists.
We learn,
right?
He has spent his life in the acquisitive arts.
That is to say he's a businessman.
He's been concerned with satisfying the needs of his body and making money.
He represents what will later be called in the republic,
the appetitive part of the soul,
the appetites,
Paula Marcus,
whose name actually means warlord.
Think of that the warlord is preoccupied with questions of honor and loyalty.
He tells us to get a little bit ahead of ourselves that justice is helping your
friends and harming your enemies.
He seems to represent what Plato or Socrates will later called a spirited part
of the soul,
something that we want to return to.
And there's civicus,
uh,
visiting surface to,
seeks to teach and educate,
anticipating what the republic will call the rational soul,
the rational part of his soul.
Each of these figures in many ways prefigure the relatively superior natures of
those who come later in the dialogue.
The two brothers Glau cone and Adyen Mantas who's exchange with Socrates
occupies for the most part,
the rest of the dialogue from book two onwards.
The two brothers who incidentally are the brothers of Plato.
Uh,
we should,
I should say we know,
to my knowledge,
we know nothing more about glaucoma and addy,
Amanda's from history,
but Plato put them into his dialogue,
put them into the,
they will always be remembered as the two brothers in the dialogue.
And again,
they seem to represent something quite different.
And bear this in mind as you are reading the book because it is easy to kind of,
uh,
forget who's talking and what they represent.
Adding a Mantis is we will find a kind of hedonistic and pleasure seeking
brother.
Okay.
And Glaucon whose name means something like gleaming,
shining,
uh,
is the fierce and warlike,
of the two brothers.
And of course there is the philosophically minded Socrates.
Again,
each of them seems to represent in a superior way.
Uh,
the key components of the human soul,
the appetitive,
the warlike or spirited,
uh,
and the rational together.
These figures farm a kind of microcosm of humanity.
Each of the participants in the dialogue represents one of the specific classes
or groups that will eventually occupy the just city to which Plato or Socrates
gives the name [inaudible] the beautiful city.
All right.
In the five minutes or so that remain,
let's,
let's just talk for a moment about the first conversation with the head of the
family capitalists.
We don't need to look at this a great length.
I want you can,
I'm sure in your sections you might want to talk about the arguments a little
more specifically that are used in two ds in these first three sets of
conversations between capitalists,
Paula,
Marcus and Thrasymachus.
The question,
more importantly,
the question,
I don't know that it's more importantly,
but the question I want us to examine a little bit here in the time remaining is
what is what again,
these,
these characters represent capitalists is his name,
implies capitalists.
What does that mean?
Do you know?
Head,
yes,
half of his head,
the head of the household,
but also clearly the claims of a age of tradition,
of family.
And at the beginning of the dialogue when Paula Marcus has brought his friends
back to the house,
we see the aged father capitalists use just returning from prayer.
He has just returned from performing certain act of ritual sacrifice and he
greets Socrates in many ways.
As a long lost friend,
perhaps you have had this experience yourself,
a slightly,
always slightly uncomfortable one.
When you bring a group of your friends,
uh,
back to your house,
you're going to have a,
you're expecting to have a good time and your grandparents is there and says,
oh,
it's so good to see a bunch of young people,
La,
uh,
I want to talk with you.
And,
uh,
it's always slightly uncomfortable,
moment too.
You might say,
we are all,
uh,
Kev experience,
of this kind of thing.
Uh,
everybody knows it from either end.
I'm not a grandparent,
thank God,
but,
uh,
I feel the same thing often when Mike's son brings his friends that I've maybe
that I've known for a long time.
And uh,
how,
how are you doing?
They don't want any,
hmm.
Want to get away?
Uh,
and Socrates does something rather,
uh,
Brock,
tell me [inaudible] what's it like to be so old?
What does it like to,
to be like you and do you still feel the need for sex?
You know,
can you imagine that saying that to someone's grandfather?
Cause you a little idea of the character of Socrates
and capitalists is so happy.
Oh,
thank God I'm past that.
He says,
you know,
thank God I no longer feel this erotic desire.
And at my old age I can spend my time.
What do you think young man,
that's all I did.
I was thinking about sex all the time.
And when I wasn't thinking about that I was making money.
But now I've had my fill of both.
And I can spend my later years,
my law,
my Dick,
the twilight of my life,
turning to the things about the gods,
performing sacrifices commanded by the gods.
When I say,
why does Plato Begin this way?
Well,
carefulness is,
as is,
should be clear,
the very embodiment of the conventional in both senses of that term.
He,
he's not a bad man by any means,
but he is a thoroughly unreflective one and an attacking capitalists as he does.
Socrates attacks the embodiment of conventional opinion,
the know most,
uh,
supporting the city.
Uh,
no the way Socrates manipulates the dialogue or the conversation capitalists has
sticked.
Keffeler says that the pious man,
the just man,
uh,
practices justice by sacrificing to the gods.
And Socrates turns that into the statement that justice means paying your debts
and returning what is owed to you.
Uh,
capitalists in an easy going manner,
agrees.
And then soccer,
he says,
well,
what would you think about returning a weapon that you had borrowed from a
friend or someone who was in a,
uh,
you know,
very depressed.
We might say depressed frame of mind.
Would,
would that be just,
uh,
how do you explain that?
Would you do that?
If justice means paying your debts,
giving back to each what,
what is owed?
And at that moment,
capitalists excuses himself from the dialogue and says,
rather abruptly,
uh,
I have to go out and,
and,
and continue,
continue,
continue my sacrifices,
uh,
in,
in the,
in the garden.
Socrates,
in other words,
has broken the bond of tradition and traditional authority that holds the
ancient city and the ancient family together.
Capitalists is banished from the dialogue.
Tread tradition is banished and we never hear another word about it for the next
400 or so pages.
Uh,
that's the way Socrates,
uh,
begins,
this,
uh,
dialogue or that's the way Plato has Socrates beginning.
And,
uh,
we'll,
we'll look,
we'll look a little more at some of these,
uh,
in our class for next time,
and then move into the characters,
uh,
of adding a mantis and Glaucon in any way.
Start your reading,
continue your reading and your,
your sessions,
your sections are going on this week.
So enjoy yourselves.